eu já vi
e aí
e já perceberam que quase toda
adolescente com 12 anos a minha
bestalhado percebeu isso
me conta uma história para vocês quando
tinha 12 anos fiz uma viagem com meu pai
a gente vai lá para salvador
a gente foi encontrar um amigo dele que
era um grande executivo de uma grande
empresa
bom então do carro desse amigo dele
estava enfim passeando e o chamado o
cara tocou
oi e ele atendeu e fez alô
oh alô
a hard-on e começou a falar inglês com
cara do outro lado naquele momento eu
pensei esse cara deve ser muito
importante que ele tá aqui dirigindo ver
o salvador cara dos estados unidos liga
para ele para ele ver um problema se
resolve com cara do outro lado
e talvez isso seja um indicador que o
cara tem muito sucesso e talvez para
saber se eu tô fazendo uma coisa levanta
e um dia alguém me liga dos estados
unidos para resolver um problema dessa
pessoa eu nasci cresci em caruaru eu vim
de uma família de comerciantes e
empreendedores meus pais tem loja lá
meus avós têm loja e eu passei minha
infância e adolescência todas as tardes
atrás de um balcão naquela naquele
empreendimento e é claro que uma criança
é achar um saco passar uma tarde vendo o
movimento lá o relação de
cliente-fornecedor funcionário eu
realmente não gostava daquilo e eu
tentava entender quando era que eu ia
deixar de fazer aquilo
eu descobri que tinha um funcionário na
loja que também odiava aquela história
eu cheguei para ele falei bora apostar
quem sai daqui primeiro
e da gente essa posta a minha é a minha
perspectiva de saída seria quando
fizesse vestibular
oi e a dele seria ele ganhar sabe esse
sorteio que tem todo final de semana
aqui dá uma casa um carro todo ele
comprava todos nós o nessa cartela
é bem um dia ele ganhou um carro e
depois foi pedir demissão e saí da loja
eu fiquei pensando poxa agora eu preciso
acelerar meu plano de saída
oi e aí no final da adolescência que tem
que escolher aquela fazer para
vestibular eu peguei o manual do
vestibular e fui ver o que era que mais
distanciava do que eu fazer todos os
dias aquele balcão
e daí eu achei a biomedicina que não
tinha parentes era biométrico não tinha
biomédica nem sabia o que era que fazia
entrei no curso e é óbvio comecei a
odiar anatomia e fisiologia bioquímica
aqui tudo é um saco para mim minhas
notas eram péssimas horríveis
e aí eu comecei a pensar que se eu
continuasse daquele jeito ele virar um
profissional frustrado
oi e me daí o ultimato quando foi mais
ou menos na metade do curso eu pensei eu
preciso decidir se eu vou continuar essa
história ou se vou parar e voltar lá
para o balcão da loja
é exatamente no quinto período comecei a
cursar uma disciplina
quem me colocou em contato com o
universo que ainda não tinha tido
experiência é divide a família de classe
média e eu nunca tinha parado para
pensar a influência que os determinantes
sociais tem na ocorrência das doenças
e como a vulnerabilidade social com a
pobreza está relacionada diretamente na
ocorrência dessas doenças em
adoecimentos e mortes a partir daquele
momento eu peguei para mim um propósito
de direcionar todo o conhecimento que eu
estava dizendo ali para resolver o
problema dessas pessoas
eu acabei a faculdade dedicado e certo
de ser um pesquisador
e aí eu me mudei para recife em para
fazer a residência
eu entrei no grupo de pesquisas que jun
tava mais um outro universo ainda não
tinha tido experiência das tecnologias e
lembrem quando 2010/2010 não era tão
comum as pessoas terem smartphones
oi gente tô nesse grupo pesquisas que
fazer exatamente esse casamento
smartphones como instrumentos de saúde
pública smartphone substituindo
pranchetas e papel dos agentes de saúde
e melhorando a informação digitava
gerando e fiz subsidiar as políticas
públicas de intervenção
e o coordenador do grupo de pesquisas
que também quero calendário de
computação trabalhava muito junto
começou a trabalhar comigo alguns
projetos específicos e as pessoas
começaram a nos perguntar quanto custava
para a gente entregar uma coisa dessa
para elas
oi e daí a gente começou avaliar não
seria melhor a gente ressignificar o
empreendedorismo e decidiu empreender é
porque a gente fez deu e as coordenador
a gente fundou uma empresa que fazer
exatamente este tipo de trabalho juntar
tecnologias óleo pública
e a gente fez um uma plataforma que foi
utilizado durante a copa do mundo para
controlar epidemias e
e aí lá a gente acabou ganhando o mundo
viajei para vários lugares do mundo para
falar e conhece toda essa plataforma
bom e quando acabou esse projeto eu
voltei para caruaru você passar uns dias
lá com a minha família
oi e o power eu também sou baterista
então tava tocando em frança minha banda
e daí eu vejo que meu telefone começa a
tocar
bom e era o número estranho
eu não lembro a hora do salvador e
pensei
bom imagina se a pessoa do estado
liliana
oi quando atende eu fiz alô
oh alô
oi rayan
bom e era uma pessoa que está desligando
e dela falou você pode falar agora por
isso claro eu tava sendo a minha barriga
ai posso falar ela disse tem alguém
perto de você aí eu tenho ela falou
então vai para um cantinho que o que eu
tenho para te falar é confidencial aí eu
mexi importada por isso não baixas e dos
estados unidos tem que ser confidencial
o e dela me disse que um grupo estava
selecionando algumas empresas para
mostrar as experiências para combater um
problema de saúde pública que estavam
vivendo mas que ela não podia me dar
muitos detalhes naquele momento dela
perguntou se eu podia ir para os estados
unidos na semana seguinte e a participar
dessa reunião pequena com esse pessoal
por isso tudo bem vamos lá
e daí foi para são francisco
e eu cheguei lá tava tendo um evento que
para a cidade inteira né toma todos os
hotéis são francisco para vender
inovação deixando aquele legal né e
pensando no amanhã outro minha reunião
depois que eu sair da reunião eu vou
fazer pouco e turismo por aqui ó
nem me chamaram para almoçar lá durante
o almoço eu conhecia quase todas as
pessoas que estavam lá umas oito pessoas
se conhecida em eventos anteriores mas
tinha um cara que eu vou fazer a noção
de quem era esse cara sentou do meu lado
era um francês e ele passou o almoço
inteiro enchendo meu saco para saber que
eu tinha feito a copa do mundo para
saber o que que eu tinha feito para
controlar epidemias durante a copa do
mundo
e eu fiquei sabe aquele aquele cara que
se passa o limite do bom senso nas
perguntas parece estar fiscalizando você
pronto é esse tipo de perfil bom
almoçamos e caminhamos para o local do
evento que a gente começa entrar num
desses hotéis que tava tendo esse grande
evento e já começou a ficar preocupado
porque eu pensei não era reunião pequena
que a gente tá fazendo aqui nesse esse
evento maior da gente entra na sala
e a fabi os 40 pessoas já começa a ficar
nervoso que achei que era minha para 8 e
eu sentei eu tava mais ou menos vestido
assim mas para entrar pessoas de terno e
gravata e fiquei com uma dúvida se eu
voltava para o hotel botar meu blazer
e mais pessoas estão em gravata eu só
vim ficar tranquilo com a minha roupa
quando entrou pela porta o japonês desse
tamanho de bermuda e regata thammy se
faz debaixo do braço
a escala pra casa ali
oi e daí o a reunião começou e eles
apresentaram naquela reunião eles tinham
selecionado oito empresas ao redor do
mundo e combate a epidemias para poder
trazer uma possibilidade de
monitoramento dos americanos que estavam
retornando duas da áfrica e tentar
identificar de maneira antecipada surto
de ebola
é só para falar que o japonês era do
google nesse explica muita coisa
oi gente tava lá
e ele tava lá apresentando a tecnologia
que desenvolveu aqui para tentar
resolver o problema do é bola lá nos
estados unidos a reunião acabou
infelizmente não foi a gente a
plataforma escolhida mas o francês me
chamou no final e disse amanhã passa no
escritório
eu tô pensando aqui que esse frasco
francês vai ferrar meu de durinho aqui
são francisco né eu fui para reunião com
ele eu cheguei lá ele falou olha a gente
desenvolve uma plataforma aqui para
controlar a influenza a gente viu que
vocês fizeram na copa do mundo de gente
que a tecnologia de vocês rodando aqui
para controlar a influência nos estados
unidos
e naquele momento o francês se tornou
meu melhor amigo ele podia perguntar o
que ele quisesse
oi gente sempre acreditou que a
sociedade estava caminhando para dar uma
casa da ação tecnológica 20 sempre
acreditou na abundância e que permite a
gente pensar novas interfaces para
acesso à saúde
oi hoje é muito difícil você conhecer
alguém que não tem whatsapp
em 2010 era escasso mas a gente
acreditar nessa mudança que tava
chegando
o nosso grande propósito esse problema
aqui de epidemias só que não são coisas
que acontecem só em fazer
subdesenvolvidos não
a mesma forma como a gente teve
recentemente um surto de zika aqui em
recife a gente tá tendo agora na suíça
um surto de sarampo
a fazer amizades não respeitam
fronteiras elas não respeitam limites
e isso é um problemas que existiram no
passado
o que acontece no presente que a gente
tem tecnologias do futuro também
acontecendo presente porque não nesses
dois modos 1
olá eu sou um construtor de pontes
e eu construo pontes entre academia e as
necessidades da sociedade eu construo
pontes do conhecimento científico e os
reais problemas e umas que a gente
precisa raptar a ciência que está sendo
produzida nos centros de pesquisa e
espalhar essa ciência pela sociedade
o preço fazer com que menos pessoas
adoeçam para gente fazer com que menos
pessoas morram
eu e meu tesão todo é tentar fazer isso
aqui decifrar o código da sobrevivência
humana decifrar aquelas situações que
matam pessoas
é porque a gente faça com que menos
pessoas têm esse fim trágico
é exatamente daqui a 24 horas eu tenho
embarcando para o malawi na áfrica
é para escrever mais um capítulo de
fazer esse estreitamento entre a ciência
e nessas idades a sociedade o gratuito
muito que abundância vai permitir que a
gente construa comunidades mais
saudáveis obrigado
e aí